now I want to talk about the funniest
[__] all right there are a few videos
online
I don't know if I'm gonna laugh at this
like I did when I first saw this
there are a few videos online
that make me laugh so hard that I just
can't do you know what I mean I it's a
good thing I was laying down in bed
because I would have just crumpled
it got me so good
I posted it on my story
and it's I think it's from that t Hanks
profile which is so funny man T dot
Hanks
and uh on Instagram and I post it and I
post on my story and this [__]
[__] dude this made me laugh
so much
here we go
um
I'm gonna play it
what the [__] with the lights
you only get one so take one
okay two you want to eat two that's good
now you put your baloney finger on it I
like this one no it's just a croissant
with the chocolate chips in it why the
[__] are you touching them all I like
this one better they're all the same no
they're not we'll get it
[Laughter]
bro when he when he oh this is so funny
okay when he hold on what the [__]
with the lights
oh [__] so hot
I didn't realize how he came in until I
watched it about six times here comes in
he comes in he's already what the [__]
with the lights just so mad already like
it's like it's probably his fault he'd
probably hit the wrong [__]
oh oh [__] dude okay and it comes in
with a gift for like his daughters you
know they look like they're in college
but he brings a [__] it and he said
he's super dead you know what I mean
he says when he says
[Laughter]
John John when he says
when he says chunk the croissants
how mad he is about the lights you know
but he went in with an idea of oh I'm
gonna make my daughter's day you know
what I mean and so he's quickly so
swallows the anger about the lights and
says chocolate croissants right okay do
it so that I loved that already so okay
so so here we go
chocolate croissant
[Laughter]
by the way it's already opened like he
already had one you know
[Music]
you can't open up those Kirkland [__]
cellophane bullshits without being so
[__] because they're always so stuck
together you know and he's like
that's right
has to go his way do you know what I
mean that's my favorite part about this
it has to go his way he needs to be
dulling him out right he wants to save
some for later whatever he's got in his
head
it's deteriorating right now he got
through the first what the [__] is wrong
with the lights happy got through it and
then his daughter's just deteriorate him
with their actions dude and it's amazing
dude it's you only get one so take one
dude I'm making a rule the rule already
first of [__] nine okay there's
literally oh I actually think there's 12
in here okay I can't really see but I
think there's 12 chocolate croissants
season they only get one so dude already
set a rule there's 12 of them you only
get one so just like I hate to break it
to you but like jonker croissants but
also you only get one okay so that's
amazing right that he's setting the rule
and then immediately daughter comes in
Scoops up too with one hand all right
now I can feel this guy's energy dude
and the [__] goes back to the what the
[__] is up with the lights but twofold
right because he already swallowed that
he probably feels like he was
like being a good person by letting the
light thing slide so now she's taken two
and I just said take one and she jumped
on it too quickly I get this dude I get
it man
okay two you want to eat two that's good
okay two you won't eat two that's good
like fuming dude
fuming to say okay good good to get okay
I said one but you get you got to you
won't eat two good dude fuming I gotta
we gotta start it over dude this is the
grid [__] you if you don't like that I'm
breaking this video down and you wish I
was doing something else on this podcast
no this is important this this is what
we need to be talking about dude this
video is absolutely tragically
unbelievable okay let's start from the
beginning again yes the lights
one so take one
two you want E2 that's good now you put
your bologna finger on it
so off the rails I don't even know what
he means by baloney figures there's two
things that he might mean and each of
them are better than the other one all
right there's two things he might mean
all right now he either means your
fingers look like baloney which is so
shitty for a dad to say all right or I
think I like this one better
they ain't baloney before this
on his croissants he Mighty later dude I
hope it's that dude
this is the greatest all right dude
let's start it over man [__] off
what the [__] is wrong with the lights
dude he's so better just watching a show
you know they're just watching a show
this guy comes in like a [__]
hurricane dude and with chocolate like a
chocolate croissant hurricane dude holy
[__] [__] man oh [__] you guys
started over we're gonna watch the whole
thing through dude
basically croissant you only get one so
take one
two you want E2 that's good now you put
your baloney finger on it I like this
one no it's just a croissant with the
chocolate chips in it why the [__] are
you touching them all I like this one
better they're all the same no they're
not we'll get it
this is
[__] off he says [__] off he says [__]
up because the daughter [__] touched
more than she shouldn't take some
employees
this guy dude I'm watching this in the
bed the first you think I'm laughing
hard now the first time I saw this I was
crying dude tears were coming up I was
rolling and rolling around and Kristen
said she said I was laughing so much
dude I laugh myself to sleep the next
morning she woke up to the bed shaking
because I was thinking
dude she woke up because the bed was
shaking because it was [__] woke up
thinking
well you got your baloney fingers
[Music]
so [__] [__] man
but when I was watching it she says you
know why you think that this is so funny
and I said why and she said it goes he
is you dude and it made so much sense
because I agree with this guy I agree
that this guy got the chocolate
croissants and he needed it should have
went his way he was nice enough to bring
the [__] chocolate croissants in for
his [__] family and they were
touching them all and doing them how he
didn't want her they ate bologna
beforehand and made the [__]
chocolate flavored bologna shits and the
lights didn't work this guy was being so
nice bringing his family 12 croissants
and his daughter came in just like
they're touching them all with baloney
fingers dude
[__] up the lights and he pays the
light bill
but in that something man that's just
how life is I thought about this clip a
lot after this
I thought about this clip a lot after
this
and that's just how life is you think
you walk into a room whatever that room
is and you got the [__] chunk the
croissants
and the people in there
they don't give a [__] about how you
feel about your chalk okay sounds
mm-hmm you know when you start a
conversation with somebody and you're in
the car and you're like when I see this
[__] I'm going to say this and
then they're going to say this and then
I'm going to say that to that
and then you get there and you're like
hey I got to talk to you about something
and they're on the phone they're like
hold on one second and you're like okay
well wait this is not something I
prepare for Life comes at you dude
everyone's not gonna feel
the same way you do about your chocolate
croissants
and this video is the funniest that's
why this video is one of the funniest
videos ever because that's what
everybody's doing when they go and they
walk into a party or they walk into an
establishment or they walk home or they
[__] get into their new car or
whatever the [__] it is you're walking
in there with some chocolate croissants
but there are other people in there
and they don't feel that way about your
[__] chocolate croissants oh [__]
they want to put their heads all over
the [__] chocolate croissants
and the lights are all [__] up anyway
anywhere when you walk in it just it
doesn't go
the way you think it is and that's it
dude
that's all I want to [__] say dude
for [__] sake this video still made me
laugh out loud